and we begin tonight with this breaking
news taking a live look here police
investigating a homicide in the
southwest part of the valley this is
near warm springs and fort apache
as you can see here a very heavy police
presence in that area
and this is actually pretty close to the
clubs at rhodes ranch apartment complex
if you're familiar with it
our mana joining us now live with more
[Music]
well denise basically what you said is
all that we know right now from metro
police but let's take a look at the
scene here again we are off of warm
springs road
in between durango and fort apache in
the southwest valley
you can see there's a heavy police
presence at this apartment complex
called
the clubs again we're counting about
five or six metro squad cars here and
other investigators on scene
again we are still working to confirm
more details about
what exactly happened here but again we
do know that metro police
is investigating a homicide here
at this apartment complex again you can
see metro squad cars and some officers
here as well the good news is traffic
along warm springs road is not being
blocked so drivers
are able to make their way through now
we are awaiting more information from
metro police in about the next 15 or so
minutes
so we will be sure to update you with
more details as we get them for now
reporting live tonight orco mana 8 news
now